[Music]
what keeps you up at night
pondering deep questions excitement
about a big trip or is it stress about
unfinished work an upcoming test or a
dreaded family gathering for many people
this stress is temporary as its cause is
quickly resolved but what if the very
thing keeping you awake was stress about
losing sleep this seemingly unsolvable
loop is at the heart of insomnia the
world's most common sleep disorder
almost anything can cause the occasional
restless night a snoring partner
physical pain or emotional distress and
extreme sleep deprivation like jet lag
can throw off your biological clock
wreaking havoc on your sleep schedule
but in most cases sleep deprivation is
short term eventually exhaustion catches
up with all of us
however some long-term conditions like
respiratory disorders gastrointestinal
problems and many others can overpower
fatigue and as sleepless nights pile up
the bedroom can start to carry
associations of restless nights wracked
with anxiety come bedtime insomniacs are
stressed so stressed their brains hijack
the stress response system flooding the
body with fight flight or freeze
chemicals cortisol and
adrenocorticotropic hormone course
through the bloodstream increasing heart
rate and blood pressure and jolting the
body into hyper arousal in this
condition the brain is hunting for
potential threats making it impossible
to ignore any slight discomfort or
nighttime noise and when insomniacs
finally do fall asleep the quality of
their rest is compromised our brains
primary source of energy is cerebral
glucose and in healthy sleep our
metabolism slows to conserve this
glucose for waking hours but PE T
studies show the adrenaline that
prevents sleep for insomniacs also
speeds up their metabolisms while they
sleep their bodies are working over
time burning through the brains supply
of energy giving glucose this symptom of
poor sleep leaves insomniacs waking in a
state of exhaustion confusion and stress
which starts the process all over again
when these cycles of stress and
restlessness last several months they're
diagnosed as chronic insomnia and while
insomnia rarely leads to death its
chemical mechanisms are similar to
anxiety attacks found in those
experiencing depression and anxiety so
suffering from any one of these
conditions increases your risk of
experiencing the other two fortunately
there are ways to break the cycle of
sleeplessness managing the stress that
leads to hyper arousal is one of our
best understood treatments for insomnia
and good sleep practices can help
rebuild your relationship with bedtime
make sure your bedroom is dark and
comfortably cool to minimize threats
during hyper arousal only use your bed
for sleeping and if you're Restless
leave the room and tire yourself out
with relaxing activities like reading
meditating or journaling regulate your
metabolism by setting consistent resting
and waking times to help orient your
body's biological clock this clock or
circadian rhythm is also sensitive to
light so avoid bright lights at night to
help tell your body that it's time for
sleep in addition to these practices
some doctors prescribe medication to aid
sleep but there aren't reliable
medications that help in all cases and
over-the-counter sleeping pills can be
highly addictive leading to withdrawal
that worsens symptoms but before seeking
any treatment make sure your
sleeplessness is actually due to
insomnia approximately 8% of patients
diagnosed with chronic insomnia are
actually suffering from a less common
genetic problem called delayed sleep
phase disorder or dspd
people with dspd have a circadian rhythm
significantly longer than 24 hours
putting their sleeping habits out of
sync with traditional sleeping hours so
while they have difficulty falling
asleep at a typical bedtime
it's not due to increased stress and
given the opportunity they can sleep
comfortably on their own delayed
schedule our sleeping and waking cycle
is a delicate balance and one that's
vital to maintain for our physical and
mental well-being for all these reasons
it's worth putting in some time and
effort to sustain a stable bedtime
routine but try not to lose any sleep
over it for more tips on how to get a
better night's rest
check out this ted-ed blog post with
seven practical sleep hacks from a
neuroscientist and if you want to watch
more ted-ed videos about sleep check out
this playlist
[Music]